he is the current UFC light heavyweight
champion taking on steep a Miocic
Saturday in Las Vegas Nevada good to
have Daniel Cormier back on the show how
you been Daniel I'm doing pretty good
thank you for having me rich oh come on
I'm just upset you're not here in person
what what happened yeah you know I mean
you know they didn't uh I didn't go on a
media tour because I went early when I
went to your show last time I went early
when the fights went on sale and Steve
pate did the media date during fight
week this time so hey we both got a
carry-out partager load whenever we're
trying to fill these papers well I'm
glad that you're you're at least getting
on the phone how what's going through
your mind right now with an opportunity
for UFC history coming up on Saturday
maintain my composure don't get too
excited know that it's coming you know
like don't rush don't try to put myself
in the arena on Thursday stay within
myself while prepping myself mentally
for the fighting and trying to let my
body recover this is one thing that is
much different as a heavyweight as
opposed to 205 right now I'd be 217
pounds and and feel like I was a walking
zombie because I would need to lose 13
more pounds and I'm already really like
hurting but with this fight a
heavyweight I can rest I can recover I
can feel like a million bucks and go out
there and do my thing on Saturday so are
you eating whatever you want how are you
getting up weight Daniel well normally
I'm a pretty big guy you know we're like
250 you know but so what it was it just
eaten very clean and and even healthy
but not worrying about weight loss you
know so yeah I mean four or five six
times a day but yesterday I had to talk
to my guy in the guy that works with my
nutritionist you know he cooks and I had
to tell Ian I go in I go listen I'm not
fighting at 205 dude gave me like one
like spicy turkey meatball and a handful
of sweet potato fries and asparagus like
yo what is going on huh like I'm not
fighting it you owe five seems like it's
205 falsely Daniel Cormier here on the
Rich Eisen show getting set to take on
ste paimio Church you want to ask him
the poll question then we're on the
subject of food here before we move
DC as you watch the hot dog eating
contest yesterday I didn't get to watch
it man I gotta be honest just I just be
honest like that I know it's an American
tradition but I don't like watching it
man they're different hot dogs in the
water and they're stuffing it on their
faces yeah because I and I'm a guy that
loves food like I can't watch this I
just can't watch it it's really hard to
watch my kids love it so I watch it
every year but I think it's kind of
weird Joe I think Joey's from San Jose
yes okay so hold on a second before you
ask them the full question uh I'm kind
of the opposite we showed my kids this
once and then the next meal the next
meal they just any manners conversation
went out the window you know what I'm
saying like there's it's it's it's not
what you want to teach to your children
you got to teach your children well I
know they think it's funny they think
it's funny like how's this little guy
eating so many hot dogs good right kids
eat a few things a pizza cheese burgers
hot dogs
he's like certain things right the
things that they like the hot dogs one
of the things that they love and they're
like how is this little guy eating so
many hot dogs but I just think it's so
bad with dipping dipping it in the water
I still don't even I don't understand it
they said the guy ate like 70 hot dogs
yeah yeah it's a performance enhancer
the dipping in the water too it puts an
asterisk on it for me it's ask Daniel
the question poll question okay DC so if
you had to be in a competitive eating
contest which food would you choose
we're going with pizza glazed donuts
shrimp cocktail and hot dogs
okay so cocktails out I'm uh I'm
allergic to shellfish okay
hamburgers you know honestly I think I
do hamburgers I had try to eat
hamburgers I'd give me a hamburger
eating contest or wings wings see we do
not know swings I bet I could do pretty
good in the wing challenge well which
time just Rhett just regular wings not
spicy I like spicy but when you eat too
many spicy later turned your lips all
red and it just makes it bad so give me
some mild like medium hot wings and I
bet I'll go to work I can I can I can
beat some guys at that okay Daniel so
the world record for chicken wings is
182 wings in 30 minutes ya know what I
am being a pig and I'm eating as many
wings as I can maybe 20 all right you
know what the problem is is like I'm
sitting over here thinking I got a
chance you're saying there's a chance
Daniel Cormier Daniel Cormier contending
for the heavyweight title against DP
Miocic Iran the Rich Eisen show is it
still your plan to retire before you
turn 40 yes it is yes it is man I I uh
want to be done by 40 I mean I've said
before you know I started just
high-level competition at 15 that was
the first time I went overseas to
represent the country in wrestling so at
40 years old I think I have had enough
and I can start to turn my focus to my
kids my daughter now is on the the
travel team for her gymnastics she
turned to c6 and she can now go around
the city of San Jose and do her
gymnastics other themes and my son is uh
he's wrestled in like six national
tournaments to this point so it's time
for the focus to be on them and you're
39 correct DC right I'm 39 years old I'm
39 years old I'm 40 in March of next
year so about yeah about nine months
left so you got this fight and and then
one more you think one or two I mean I
can squeeze them in like I said you know
I still like the fight but um I just
think the focus needs to shift but if
I'm quick if I don't get beat up too bad
on Saturday you know not mean and I lose
I'm talking about like getting my face
split hammer bleeding too much
I bet I can get back in there by October
November and then be back in there by
March you know so I can probably squeeze
two more well what are your loved ones
think of when you they hear you talking
that way Daniel my wife thinks that I'm
crazy she thinks that I need
competitions I'm not gonna want to
retire she's not forcing this on me
she's just calling you're not gonna want
to be done I'm like no I said I think
it's a little bit like oh I want it
going good more time with you guys I
don't want to be eight weeks in training
camp where
I see my family and pastors no like I'm
home I sleep I go back to the gym two
three times a day so I want to go to
just say you know what let's go on a
vacation let's go
Disneyland this weekend and pop on the
flight and not worry about some of the
other issues that keep me back home now
so yeah she has a big that I want to do
it she don't think that I'll be able to
stick to it but I'm pretty certain I'll
be okay so then it goes well with steep
a who you - are you targeting is this is
this a Lesnar situation still yeah you
know that would be fun but I mean there
are some things that Bronx wouldn't have
to do and in it and if he does those
things and it'll work with the timeline
like I said you know I want to fight
against sue so Brock would need to get
back into the asana testing pool because
I think he has like a four six month
period before he can fight of being
tested by you sada so that would have to
take some time so he would need to do
that as soon as possible but yeah I'd
love to fight Brock you know I obviously
the other guy is Jones but I mean who
knows when that guys comes back after
all the stuff that he's got himself at
you and then what are your thoughts on
you know if you want to put your your
your analyst hat on because again your
co-host of UFC tonight as well the max
Holloway news you're the I guess the
co-main event is no longer an event at
all now that he had to step aside
taking on Ortega where is that scary
it's very scary because max max is a guy
that I've known for a little bit now and
I spend time with him and you can see
that he wasn't like him he just looked
tired right look like really really
tired and last week he was more why all
the way to New York to do a media day so
I thought maybe he was just tired from
the travel but he said he just didn't
feel like himself going and I think that
in those situations especially with the
brain his management team his the UFC
they did a great job recognizing that
max wasn't himself and taking him out of
the fight because ultimately health is
the most important thing this guy has a
young son
and he needs to make sure his family's
took care of it sucks for the car it
sucks for for him and in in terms of a
money-making opportunity but ultimately
the best decision was me all right
for let you go you know he had steep a
on Monday here in studio as we alluded
to at the beginning he as you say he did
the the heavy lifting in studio this
week you did it previously okay for the
pay-per-view promotion I asked him to
leave you a message are you ready for it
Daniel okay okay
it didn't I'll be honest with you it
didn't go as I had hoped okay but that's
just here's what he's had to say we're
gonna have Daniel on later on the week
should I you want to give him a message
for later on we could play it for him
I'll be doing good let's see this week
let's take two here
steep a Miocic leaving Daniel Cormier a
message when he calls in on Thursday
hey Daniel steep a hope you doing well
[Laughter]
so much he's got so much material to
like they know you're old you're short
like what are you doing you're gonna get
smashed yeah nice is here man
that's how he is you know Steve a
meiosis is a genuinely good guy and I
kind of well you said it didn't go as I
thought I expected that type of message
two nice guys on UFC 226 and talk it out
yeah I just they're gonna just you know
right guys that are like oh don't don't
we'll go in there and we'll try to rip
each other's heads off I promise you
every punch I will throw is with the
worst intentions so as nice as he is I
want to bash his face in see a priest
all of it hey look let's check down the
line okay always enjoy our competitions
thank you I appreciate you guys always
haven't you got it as always at DC
underscore MMA Daniel Cormier taking on
steep a Miocic the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience